hey youtubers is Charlie so by popular
demand this is gonna be my personal Q&A
video where I just answer questions that
you guys ask me about myself I totally
love answering questions like these I
don't have any problem answering them
it's just that personally I don't find
you know the things that I do more
interesting than what's going on and the
Song of Ice and Fire or on Doctor Who
and stuff so that's why I don't do a lot
of vlogs all the time I also wanted to
give you guys an update on you know
giveaways that are going on and things
that are coming up so I'm gonna be at
Anime Expo this coming weekend I'm not
gonna be there every single day but I
will be announcing on like Twitter and
Facebook when I'm gonna be around and
just in case you guys haven't seen I'm
doing a weekly Game of Thrones giveaway
as part of my Game of Thrones bonus
videos and a weekly Korra giveaway is
part of those videos so I'll have links
for all that stuff in the description so
let's get to the important stuff weird
questions about me so first question
tanki asks what is your family
background in terms of what country they
came from etc so I'm about as white as
you can get although historically my
family's from like somewhere between the
border of France and Germany but I'm
like you know fourth or fifth generation
American but technically I guess you
would call me German question number two
Tom enter asks what career have you had
in the past and what are your goals for
emergency awesome are you using it as a
stepping-stone to something greater
you've mentioned in the past that you'd
like to work with HBO so there's yeah a
lot of questions good questions
essentially I've done a lot of stuff in
the past so like right after school I
worked in the financial industry for a
long time and then after that I
basically kind of went back to school
got a film degree I actually have two
degrees my first degree is in psychology
my second one is in film and business
and that's where I started doing YouTube
stuff I started working with a company
called next new networks that got bought
out by YouTube so a lot of the stuff
that we did there form the foundation
for what they tell other youtubers to do
to make their channels big to grow their
audiences so that was just like pure fun
time but I almost got paid no money but
it was so much fun as the channel gets
bigger and bigger there are some things
that I'd like to do that I haven't done
yet like charity work but I'll be making
announcements about that later this year
so there are some things I'm really
excited about in terms of like
stepping-stone and stuff like that no I
don't have any intention of ever trying
to do like a TV show or you know we're
with HBO like that so typically when I
work with networks is to create like
special videos when certain things are
coming out like BBC America approached
me last year about doing a couple
special Doctor Who videos and that's
where they sent me this TARDIS that you
guys see but there's no like business
ease stuff going on you know it's just
like you and your friend you know
talking about a certain show on Twitter
except I'm doing it in video question
number three Alex asks how old were you
when you read Storm of Swords so yeah I
actually read the george RR martin books
like way after they came out because
they came out like a long time ago I
would say I was like mid to like late
20s so I basically read like the first
four books and then I had to wait a
couple years for Dance with Dragons to
come out question number four waddle my
friend asks can I give you a gift I'd
like to send you something from the UK
so thank you so much a lot of you have
actually asked about sending me like
physical things or like letters or
something like that I don't have one
right now but I will get one in the
future so whenever that happens I will
make an announcement so in case you guys
ever want to send me like physical
actual things question number five Emily
Whittle asks why did you start making
videos so I'd actually been working on
YouTube for a long time I think I
started working on YouTube it was like
late 2007 just working on other people's
channels is like an editor or like an
intern but just because cameras are so
expensive and for a long time I didn't
have a ton of money to spend on stuff
like that I just didn't have the
equipment to make videos but then
finally I got a little bit of money so I
bought a camera and it was right around
the 2012 Doctor Who Christmas special
and I really wanted to talk about it so
I thought it'd be fun to make a video
and it was terrible and then I made
another video and it was a little bit
better and so on and so on and then I
just arrived you know where you see me
right here question number six what kind
of rig do you have so it's just like a
core i7 PC with like a 660 GTS it's
nothing crazy but it's just you know
built to help me edit stuff faster
question number seven in real Molly asks
do you watch the football or you know
soccer championships I assume you're
talking about the World Cup no I'm not
really following the World Cup like I
follow the news on social like on
Twitter and Facebook and stuff but I
don't have like a favorite team so
there's nobody I'm really rooting for
question number eight Adam Eve asks
what's your educational background so
originally I got a degree in psychology
I was also a swimmer like an NCAA
swimmer whenever
an undergraduate and then it went back
to school later for business and film
just because whenever I started doing
YouTube stuff and working on web video I
didn't really have a background and
creative film or anything like that
question number nine are you ever gonna
do a podcast or a collab channel so I
love listening to podcasts but I'm not a
big fan of making podcasts like I just
like doing videos so you'll always just
see me doing this type of stuff as for a
collab channel it really just depends on
how much time I have because I always
have lots of good ideas that I just
don't have time for so if I ever meet
someone that I think can help me make
one of those ideas happen then yeah
probably try to do something like that
question number 10 lauren shala asks
what editing software do you use so it's
mostly Adobe Creative Suite pretty much
just Premiere Pro and Adobe Photoshop
just really simple question number 11
will you be a Comic Con this year so I'm
not actually sure if I'm going to be a
Comic Con or not I might be doing a
panel but I'll make an announcement
about that whenever we get closer
question number 11 which conventions do
you like to go to and do you go to any
international conventions so I haven't
really been going to a lot of
conventions lately just because I have
like a day job and I'm trying to make
youtube videos so I don't have a lot of
time but next year my hope is to travel
a lot more
so there are any big conventions in like
Australia or England or anywhere else
that you guys really think that I should
go to just please let me know question
number 12
Bing mate asks do you ever plan on
hiring people to help you make videos
did you ever end up finding a new
apartment so no obviously this all looks
the same so I haven't moved anywhere as
for hiring people no I have no intention
of hiring people personally I really
just like being able to do all this
myself but obviously someday I'm gonna
try and start a family so I won't have
as much time to make videos so I'm sure
at some point I will need to have
someone help me out I totally realized
that I'm like way off on the numbering
thing but number 15
Luke Jordan which do you prefer Game of
Thrones or The Walking Dead so I have a
longer history with Game of Thrones so I
guess technically you could call that my
favorite thing but The Walking Dead is
like this big vast universe that I'm
slowly getting into more and more it's
just that I haven't read as much of the
written material for Walking Dead as I
have for Game of Thrones question number
16 the clock bunk asks where do you get
all your wallpapers from stuff like this
is like something I did in Photoshop
like this doesn't
in the wild like I had to make this
myself or sometimes it's just screen
caps from the videos I make pushing
number 17 Jeremy asks what house best
fits your persona I guess you could say
House Stark just because you know winter
is coming just the idea means that
they're preparing for something really
bad to happen and I tend to be pretty
careful like in my personal life
question number 18 hermit the crab asks
what did you major in well like I said
my undergraduate degree was in
psychology but I actually got into
college on an engineering scholarship
like mechanical engineering
whenever I switched to psychology I
still got to keep the engineering
scholarship - that was pretty cool
question number 18 the Shamus asks you
always ask people not to put piratebay
links and stuff in your videos is that
because you work with Studios no I don't
have any official arrangement with
studios or anything like that it's just
that whenever you put stuff like that in
the comments it's always just one more
reason for a studio to ask you to take a
video down and I spent so much time
making videos to have them take it down
is basically just to invalidate like 6
to 8 hours of my life question number 19
what are your favorite TV shows and
books to read and are you reading
anything right now so I'm actually
reading a couple comic books right now
I'm reading original sin from Marvel and
Bryan cave on saga those are actually
really awesome comic books you should
check out there's actually a new Game of
Thrones short story out it's like a
prequel to the dance of dragons that's
for like favorite TV shows I would say
like you know anything you see on my
channel is like a favorite show of mine
because if I'm gonna spend like eight
hours making a video it better be
something that I really enjoy otherwise
it's just gonna be agony question number
20 how do you deal with spoilery info
that leaks on movies and TV shows and
what do you do whenever episodes leak
like the flash so whenever stuff leaks
like Korra and the flash typically I try
to avoid doing like really spoiler
videos on it if you end up showing some
of the stuff that got leaked that's
actually super illegal which is why you
don't see me doing a lot of like
spoilery flash videos question number 21
sergio asks if you were in the last
airbender cory universe what element
would you bend a price a earthbending
because I would like to be able to
metalbend I feel like that would be
really cool either that or firebending
so that I could lightning Bend I always
like the sub style it's all about that
sub style question 22 what do you do
when you're not making videos I mostly
take naps and eat candy question 23 do
you have any advice for me about
becoming a you
uber I would say just find something
that you're really passionate about make
a video about it you know set up a
schedule and communicate what that
schedule is and all the videos that you
make so that people that find your
channel know when those videos are
coming and what they're gonna be so I
totally forgot which number I'm on but
I'm gonna say 24 maybe 23 who are your
favorite youtubers right now I would say
my favorite youtubers have always been
the vlogbrothers but aside from that I
really like to watch youtubers that do
things that I don't do like if you're a
big nerdfighter then you probably watch
a lot of the same channels that I watch
question 25 Heather you actually had a
really funny comment so I'm gonna read
it all if you don't have a girlfriend
you really should I'm married and
probably 15 years older than you so take
this as a big sister comment and not
anything creepy but you're just adorable
find a good girl in nerd nation and
settle down
thank you that's just really nice
question 26 what are your favorite
things about YouTube or being a youtuber
and is there anything that you really
hate about it
so I would say I both love and hate the
comment system like the comments are
actually the most important part of
YouTube it's what distinguishes YouTube
from like other video platforms it's
much like you know Yahoo
is like vastly less successful than
YouTube just because there's no
community the comments really are the
community question number 27 are you
ever gonna do t-shirts so no I don't
have any plans to do anything like that
any time soon you know maybe next year I
might do something either with like my
avatar or you know like fandom related
you have to be really careful with
license and stuff like that like if I
made a Doctor Who t-shirt then the
Doctor Who people who come and sue me
question 28 what games are you playing
right now so I actually just bought
valiant hearts so I'm really looking
forward to playing that question 29 if
you could collab with any youtuber who
would it be
I would probably say like you know
somebody who is really good at building
Lego models I'd really like to do like a
time lapse video like the Game of
Thrones intro you know only done with
Legos stuff like that that would be a
lot of fun and last one question 30 if
you can live in any country where would
it be so I guess you know if you know
language economics and internet
connections and stuff like that weren't
really a concern I would totally like to
live in Hobbiton like in New Zealand
that'd be really fun so thank you so
much everyone for so many questions I
always love doing videos like this I
totally don't mind answering personal
questions it's just I don't think that
you know daily vlogs for me would be
quite as
as the other videos I make which is why
you don't see me doing this more often
because there are a few big milestones
that I think are going to be happening
this year I'm gonna be announcing some
special events whenever I get closer to
them it's gonna be like November
December before that happens but I
really would like to start doing some
charity work so when we get closer to
that I'll make some announcements and a
lot of you been asking me yes there is a
game of Thrones bonus video coming
tonight be sure to subscribe to get it
if you're just finding me for the first
time it might be a little bit longer but
I'm really excited about it I'll try to
post that by like 9 p.m. Pacific time
you can click here to get it all I the
annotation as soon as I post it heads up
it's all about white Walker theories so
and you can also click here to learn all
about the new Doctor Who trailer thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight
high fives